freedom
you say america and it's probably the
next word that comes to mind
it's our fundamental right to live our
lives however we want
but freedom isn't something we've always
had
when i was 18 i joined the air force and
i did
well enough on my test to qualify as an
electronic countermeasures operator
but i was told i couldn't take that job
apparently no black man could fly with
the strategic air command
abraham lincoln knew that a country
could only truly stand for freedom
if it applied to all of its people
around the world there's a growing tide
of freedom
the belief that every person has the
right to self-determination is growing
stronger
and stronger
i wonder if one day we will all be free
what drives people to fight for freedom
five months before elections they told
everybody pushing will be the next
president i was just really
angry can we find liberty
even when bound and changed my mind
emotions were
beyond the confines of that self and
when will everyone be free to be who
they really
are i want to wear a burqa so nobody
sees me as a boy that's when i felt what
freedom really meant
this is my journey
to discover the ties that bind us
and the common humanity inside us
this is the story of us
i'm going to meet a man who was born a
slave
shin dong began his life in a north
korean labor camp
it was the only world he knew until he
was 23 years old
i wonder what freedom means for someone
who first encounters it
as an adult shin
and his wife leanne are meeting me in
new york city to tell me his story
yeah yes how do you do good
so
how long have you been married two years
two years yeah this april
is that a long time yet yeah yeah
both it feels long at the same time it
feels like it was just yesterday
okay you got it got you out of holding
you've been freed down for what
11 years 11 years yeah okay
but you were born in a slave labor camp
yeah so how did it come about that you
were going to be
born there my parents
go in the camp was born in the camp they
were political prisoners
yes the united nations estimates there
are about a hundred thousand political
prisoners in north korea
you can be thrown into a prison camp
simply by speaking ill of the country's
leader
just talk to me a little bit about daily
life while you were in the camp
you you were there for a long time
we woke up around 4am and there would be
some kind of signal
either a bell maybe a speaker and we
would know it's time to go and work so
we'd do
whatever task it would be
it could be farming corn rice it could
be working in the coal mines
none of us had dreams or hopes for the
future
it was just so natural that's just the
way it was
going there live there died there
if we do something wrong or don't work
well the guards would give us an option
you can either starve or get b
so one of the rules that we learn is
that we are never
ever supposed to eat anything um that is
not given to us
this little girl was probably six or
seven at the time but
she must have came across something to
eat and she didn't want to eat it all at
once
and she must have wanted to save it so
she had to hit it in her pocket
and one of the guards had said why
didn't you follow the rules
you know better than that and he
repeatedly hit her on her head
and eventually she passed out
yeah the next day
she didn't come to class so the guard
sent us to go get her but
when we got to the house she was dead
they beat this child
to death thank god they didn't go
what about your parents
really sad but they were just fellow
prisoners to me i didn't have any
sense of family
the hardest thing in my whole life is
probably the memory of my mom and my
brother i learned
as a child that i'm supposed to report
to the guards at any point
on my own parents you know report if
they're doing anything wrong
and the more i report on them the better
off
it is for me so i thought they were
escaping
and i reported on them
i really had no anticipation or thoughts
of what would come from that
there were many people gathered and my
father and i
were forced to watch their execution
but honestly i really had no
emotion
deserved
later shin recalls meeting a fellow
prisoner named park
a man who traveled throughout north
korea and china
he intoxicated shin with descriptions of
life lived freely
and life with food
but the things that were the most
fascinating was the way he was able to
express and explain the foods he ate
like pork
the way he would describe it was so
interesting and it just
pulled me in some might consider it kind
of foolish or
humorous but for me it was something as
simple as food
it was that simple thought that kind of
drove me initially
to run
in 2005 january 2nd we were tasked to
work near the fence i had actually been
the one to
initially say maybe this is the time we
should try
according to shin when they made their
break
park arrived at the fence first
but he accidentally touched the electric
wire
only shin made it through alive
really had no idea what to do or where
to go all i knew was that i needed to
get away as far as possible
of course of course
shin crossed the board into china and
survived by working
odd jobs he made his way to shanghai
and from there gained passage to seoul
in south korea
shin had freed his body but he began to
realize his mind was still enslaved
you're free how did that feeling many
times
come to south korea in the night there's
a sleep
nightmare yeah
and because of the nightmares and the
mental distress i couldn't even eat
i was diagnosed with severe ptsd
and from that point is when i started
having questions in my head about
life and how long were you in south
korea
about 10 years 10 years it's a long time
to get acclimated
which brings up you yeah
from when i first saw her i i liked her
right away and i thought she was
pretty and um within a few days i asked
if she had a boyfriend and
it's very brave very very afraid i must
say
marrying leanne and choosing to start a
family was for shin
a decisive break from the chains that
had bound him for so long
it was so hard for me to comprehend and
look at the world around me where
parents love their children and feed
their children and clothe their children
and care for them
but now that we are expecting our son i
see how my wife is preparing for it and
i see
that there is a child growing inside of
her and i just see the world differently
question hi thank you so very much thank
you very much thank you we really
appreciate you coming and doing this
hope to see you again
all right that's a good idea
thank you so nice meeting you take care
of that young thank you
okay bye bye bye
[Music]
shin didn't suddenly feel free he had to
learn
what freedom is experiencing the joy and
challenges of life all the complex
choices you have to make
he has made those choices he's got
married he has a kid on the way
and that that's what gives freedom
meaning
freedom is a state of mind
and this man is living proof of that
he found a way to be free even though
his body
was utterly trapped
for 43 years
i'm headed to louisiana
to meet albert woodfox he was imprisoned
here
in angola state penitentiary for most of
his life
originally convicted of armed robbery at
age 18
he ended up in solitary confinement for
longer than anyone else in american
history
aha mr woodford freeman welcome to my
home
nice to meet you i would expect anyone
who spends four decades in solitary
to emerge with a broken soul and
deadened mind but albert appears healthy
and well adjusted i've come to find out
how so what got you in prison
i was a predator in my own community you
know a petty criminal a person of the
street
i was on discipline unmotivated and
stuff but
my crime for going to prison was an
armed robbery charge
did you go straight to angola when you
were convicted no i actually escaped
the very day i was sentenced to 50 years
okay all right you escaped you're out
for a little while
well i went to new york you went to new
york it was a defining moment in my life
because
while in harlem i had an up-close
encounter with the black panther party
[Music]
i had always noticed a certain fear in
african-americans
even those who defied their hearts and
achieve
certain goals in life for the first time
in my life
where i seen black people and i didn't
see that pier i didn't feel that fear
talking about revolution and organizing
the black community to protect the
people
some of the sisters that although they
possessed our beauty it was the inner
beauty that i was seeing it was the
strength the determination the sense of
purpose
i was profoundly shocked when i realized
that hey
i am worried something i do matter
i actually joined black panther party
okay but i got arrested again and i was
eventually uh
extradited back to louisiana and after
that they shipped me to angola
uh in 71.
but it was an incident a year after his
arrival at angola that would change the
course of albert's life
a prison guard was found murdered april
17th 1972 they found a correctional
officer named brent miller
murdered in one of the units each unit
has four dormitories
and i was in the very last unit even
though albert's unit was nowhere near
the scene of the crime
prison authorities accused him of the
murder did they ever find out who did it
well they they could've they had a
bloody thing identified with bloody
fingerprint on the door
they had the fingerprints at every
prisoner in angola at that time
they couldn't find out who that
fingerprint was for
albert believes he and two other inmates
were framed because of their affiliation
with the black panthers
they labeled me a militant during that
time a militant
meant she was a panther i was placed in
a south american family april 18
1972 and i didn't get out of solitary
confinement until
february 19 2016.
albert and the other two inmates each
spent decades in solitary confinement
they became known as the angola iii
human rights groups around the world
declared their punishment cruel
and inhumane well this room is a little
bigger than the cell
to give you some idea of the size of
cell we
lived in in south confinement the cell
is approximately you know nine feet long
and six feet wide
this is the length of it yes good lord
so you have a very narrow pad that you
can walk up and down
set
how much time you spend in this space uh
23 hours out of day
23 hours every day every day
seven days a week seven days a week 365
days a year
it's a living nightmare filled with one
horror after another
that's the only way i can describe
prison
the strip search now that is one of the
most humiliating
experiences you could go through and you
have to stand before these people and
script
completely naked and you have to you
know
raise your genitals and open your mouth
and
you know this is what they used to do
our ancestors on slave blocks
and so we started resisting you know we
wouldn't do it you know they would
tell you strip and you refuse and they'd
beat you and tear your clothes off
and stuff slam it on on the desk i don't
know how many times
i got beat alba's physical world was
incredibly small
and oppressive but he refused to let his
cage confine him
that would seem to close the mind
amber didn't close yours
i never thought about being in the cell
my mind emotions and all that were
beyond the confines of that self
i said that if me dying in solitary
confinement
become a better human being and to make
those around me
better it would be worth it i started
trying to raise the level of conscience
of the prisoners in the dormitory i
lived in
educate agitate organize against
prison corruption prison brutality
albert had freed his mind
even though his body remained confined
we
are deeply disappointed that mr woodfox
will not be released today twice alban
had his conviction overturned
twice more the state imposed new charges
finally government officials offered to
release albert if he pleaded
no contest to lesser charges
on his 69th birthday after 43 years and
10 months in solitary
albert woodfox became the last of the
angola 3 to be released
albert's body finally followed his mind
to freedom
he's finally reunited with his family
and he gets to enjoy being a great
grandfather
he's also an advocate for prisoners
rights
you were amazed at people who were black
but not afraid and i think
part of your freedom while incarcerated
is freedom from fear because if you had
been afraid you wouldn't have done any
of that
no i don't think i could every time
you know uh i had to take a stand
and knowing that there would be some
retribution
you know but still overcoming the fear
finding the strength
let's see i'm st i still got to do this
i have to do this that spell c-o-u
our
thank you
albert woodfox had four decades in
solitary confinement to think about
freedom
in prison he learned to cast off the
chains that bound him physically
and found an inner freedom nelson
mandela said
to be free is not merely to cast off
one's chains but to live in a way that
respects and enhances the freedom of
others
[Music]
something we must all strive for
life without the concept of freedom
seems alien to most of us today
for most of recorded history freedom was
the domain
of only a select few royalty
nobility and the wealthy
but in 1776 13 british colonies in north
america
dared to declare freedom as a basic
human right
i'm headed to the american philosophical
society in philadelphia
to meet with its librarian patrick spiro
he studies documents dating back to the
time of the country's founding
what you're looking at here is one of
the first printings
of the declaration of independence the
first section is the preamble
and this is where they talk about life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and the idea is that individuals should
be free
to do these things and government is
constituted to protect
those free traders and what the king has
done is
broken that contract broken that trust
and so they have to be freed from
the king in order to be free to do what
they want
now can you say that this was the first
time a group of people
decided that they wanted to be free to
do whatever the
heck they wanted to do well i think it's
uh the first time
that it was ever written in a official
way
but this is not the only version of the
declaration of independence that
survives
the other document that i want to show
you is this thomas jefferson's
draft of the declaration of independence
and you can see on the side there's
these notes
yeah once congress got their hands on
this they started changing words
changing meanings
i think the most notable one is in that
famous phrase
that people are endowed with certain
unalienable rights
jefferson originally wrote inherent
and inalienable rights inherent rights
which jefferson used several times
means that all people are born with
these rights
okay so if these rights are not inherent
then you're not necessarily born with
them only a few people are born with
them
and that applied only to white society
like mayo yes yes
it never occurred to me that the rights
to freedom spelled out in the
declaration of independence were
deliberately phrased
to exclude slaves and women
thomas jefferson's original draft
preserved here in the american
philosophical society
describes the rights as inherent meaning
they should apply to everybody from
birth but the final
signed version only describes
certain unalienable rights
in other words only rights landowning
white men
already had couldn't be taken away
the declaration of independence
it says that all men are created equal
that's not what it meant
they aren't writing for the enslaved
they aren't
writing for women the thing is about
this document
is that slavery existed in this period
but the word is never used
and they're purposeful about not using
it because they know
that it does not comport with the idea
of liberty that there's that
contradiction that paradox
is it safe to say that jefferson was
probably one of our
most enigmatic
presidents yes well you know
the thing is jefferson was imperfect you
know
jefferson had slaves jefferson's
imperfections
got at the american paradox okay
so the declaration of independence is
not
a document guaranteeing freedom
yes i think that's fair
but once you put that writing in stone
it empowered
people it inspired people it drove them
to realize
what those words meant couldn't mean
well it took a lot of fighting and
effort heroic actions
bravery people willing to risk their
lives to realize the promise
of the declaration
the declaration of independence was not
designed
to free everyone in america its original
purpose
was to free powerful american land
owners
from any obligations to the king of
england
but once those white men had signed
that document they unwittingly opened
the road
to freedom for the rest of us to walk
along
[Music]
freedom doesn't come without a fight
what american revolutionaries fought for
over two centuries ago
other revolutionaries continue to battle
for
today
i've come to guatemala to meet freedom
fighter and nobel peace prize winner
rigoberton minchu a guatemalan
indian rights activist who fled her
country in 1981
after security forces killed her family
she has dedicated her life to securing a
better future for the indigenous peoples
of her country
hello hello hello senor freeman
[Music]
rico belgium belongs to the kiche one of
over 20 indigenous groups of mayan
descent
which make up about half of guatemala's
population
for centuries the mayan were denied
voting rights and land ownership
and were forced to labor on plantations
some of the worst oppression came during
the 36-year guatemalan civil war
when tens of thousands of maya were
kidnapped
tortured and murdered
rigoberta gave voice to the plight of
her people with an oral testimony that
would become
her book i regobella them in jewel
that book seems to make quite an impact
why do you think that is
it's full of primera
i was the first guatemalan that was able
to talk about what was happening here in
guatemala
i think guatemala was a laboratory for
cruelty that
they practice torture they practice
forced disappearance
and they practice brutal hatred against
the mayans
rider belt's father began organizing
rural workers and fighting for
indigenous rights
but he drew the attention of the regime
which was bent on rooting out guerrillas
the war reached my home in 1979.
and then he was tortured and then he was
shot to death
on january thirty first nineteen eighty
regal barrage's father joined a group of
activists occupying the spanish embassy
in guatemala city
they were protesting massacres and
kidnappings
taken place in the countryside
the authorities ordered a raid but then
the embassy caught fire
and police blocked the exits
it was in the embassy on fire
see
this was
three months after the death of my
father my mother was kidnapped
and she suffered the worst of the
torture despite others
and then another one of my brothers had
been shot to death
your father to mama
two brothers those are six
the sisters of the sacred family brought
me to guatemala city
[Music]
they were able to get me out hide me
with religious orders in mexico
how long were you there for 14 years 14
years
so i made a promise to fight against
impunity for the rest of my life
my converting and i became
a spokesperson for guatemala
rigoberta traveled around the world
spreading the story of the maya's quest
for freedom
she addressed the united nations
in 1992 she won the nobel peace prize
her tireless work brought international
pressure on guatemala's government
and helped lead the way to peace
in guatemala just as in the civil rights
movement in the u.s
some people chose to fight for freedom
with the sword
while others chose the pen it is those
who chose
the path of peace i believe who laid the
foundation for real change
if freedom is ever going to become a
universal human right
it needs people willing to champion it
no matter what the danger
i'm headed to new york to meet a woman
who is fearless
in her march for freedom
nadia tolokonikova
is a founding member of [ __ ] riot a
russian protest
rock band
in 2012 [ __ ] ryan staged a flash
concert
inside a moscow cathedral
their aim was to draw attention to what
they saw
as suppression of democratic freedoms by
russian president vladimir putin
with the collusion of the russian church
nadia's musical protest cost her 22
months in prison
she's free now living in new york
and she refuses to be cowed into silence
[Music]
now the name [ __ ] riot very outgoing
and daring and
ear catching gets people's attention how
many of you started this
me and my friend cut mm-hmm but we have
open membership
because the idea was to start a movement
and so everybody could join
your group the reason you got arrested
was
you did this wrong your performance in a
church
why did you do that was it because you
knew you would get arrested and draw a
lot of attention
or i was just really angry because
i woke up one morning and they told it
everybody in my country that was ever
put into the next president
so like five months before the elections
they just announced it
i was confused i i didn't really
like it
you went to jail
what was that like it made me more
stubborn i was stubborn before but
it made me more focused
if you're able to find inspiration in
everything
then you could find inspiration in jail
too
but it doesn't change the fact that you
don't have any medication the conditions
are
terrible i was approached by a lot of
women in my camp and they told me
like look you're the only one person who
could actually help us
you have media and you have lawyers and
you have
voice so just tell what's going on in
this prison
nadia now had another oppressor of
freedom to target
russian prison authorities
she staged multiple hunger strikes and
drafted letters of protest so i was
writing these papers to all these
different prison officials
about what i want from them i wanted
them uh improve the food
i wanted them to improve their
conditions well i mean make enough noise
if it seems to me that they would want
to
shut you completely up stick a needle in
your neck and
you die you're never worried about that
it could happen yeah it would happen
even while she was locked in a russian
prison
nadia tolokonikova remained a freedom
fighter
battling for basic human rights for
inmates
so i wrote an open letter and then
somehow sneaked with this open letter
and they
passed it to the free world and it's all
over the world it's in the biggest
russian media and it's in guardians and
times and because it is everywhere
i did achieve something because several
guys who were in
my prison officials they were fired from
their jobs
what do you hope to do ultimately
i think i'm just trying to build this
community all around the world
you could you could create some wave of
inspiration of
or energy and then you could inspire
some other people if you can inspire
five people around you that's enough
because
if that five people inspire somebody
else and then it just
will grow i think freedom is a process
it's not an idea it's a process of
exploring
yourself and your existence in the world
would you have freedom from wage slavery
then join in the grand industrial band
would you from misery and hunger be free
then come do you share
nadia fights for freedom wherever she
sees people without it
in russia she fought for democratic
rights
in prison she fought for human rights
[Music]
in america she's singing an early 20th
century workers rights tune
reflecting one of her new fights the
freedom
to join labor unions
[Music]
freedom may be an eternal principle but
in reality
freedom will wither and die unless
people like nadia
fight for it rejuvenated
[Music]
worshipped
[Music]
most freedom fighters struggle against
outside oppressors
kings governments or prison guards
but there's another form of freedom
the freedom to be and to be seen
as who we really are
i'm meeting victoria khan a woman who
has fought for freedom
in every aspect of her life
she grew up in afghanistan during the
tumult of the early 90s
the taliban were gaining a foothold but
were being fought by homegrown rebel
groups led by
ahmad shah massoud
you have quite a story to tell me start
way back
and tell me i was born in afghanistan
and my parents were working for
ahumachamasu my mom and dad
adored me of course and i have a little
sister
the civil war breaks out somewhere when
you're around six or seven years old
so one night there's something you can
feel there's loud and screaming and
gunshots
and everyone's home had hidden areas
and my mom and dad they put us both of
us in there
i remember my mom saying don't you come
out until
everything is quiet then they kissed us
they said take care of your sister and
that was it
can you tell me what happened when you
came up
street was full of
dead bodies blood it's impossible to
recognize who's who
not only they shot people they chopped
off hats
chopped off body parts
did you find your parents no
after the parents were killed all the
children were taken by
molasses and these imams in molasses
would pick i'll take him her him her
girl i did that for i would say maybe
four or five months
until i saw a dizzy mom on top of my
sister
molesting her and she was five and a
half years old
so when he went to prayer room ran into
the house grabbed my sister and i put
her number because she couldn't even
walk she was
bleeding and
i carried around my back maybe a few
miles until we found a woman who was
sitting outside her home
she took us in and gave us some dry
bread and water
but then she told us she's going to take
us to some very safe place
it was a wahabi camp for children
where they start telling you how
become a suicide bomber but they're not
going to just on front
coming up and say we're going to train
you to become a suicide bomber
you're wanting to be because they say
you're going to meet your mom and dad
and we really really wanted to see our
parents
just as victoria believed she was about
to be shipped to pakistan for more
jihadi training
the rebel leader ahmed shah massoud
attacked the wahhabi camp
maybe 40 50 fighters comes in the horses
with their
weapons
oh my god this person's gonna save me
kills every single one of these people
who are
torturing these children so he rescues
every one of us
five six hundred children
he was not just the leader of our
country he was a spiritual leader
savior savior that's what i was looking
for
after victoria and her sister were
liberated
a woman offered them safe passage to
tajikistan
so get this woman she's taking you now
to
tajikistan yes we're crossing a border
i'm crying i said i don't want to be
separated
from my sister i want to wear a burqa so
nobody
sees me as a boy
you were not a girl i was in the boy's
body
i look skinny little persian boy
physically
and beautiful girl inside
many people today fight for the freedom
to live as their minds and spirits
compel them to
but victoria khan's struggle to free her
true self
was coupled with a long battle to stay
alive
as a transgender woman she grew up in
afghanistan being seen
as a boy but while crossing the border
into tajikistan with her younger sister
victoria wanted to make sure they were
not separated
so she put on a burqa
the burqa was that lightning stroke
which says yes
when i put it on that's the first time
that i felt
what freedom really meant it felt
so right first time i felt like it's
like
wings i had in my back that i could fly
okay
now i get the taste of that now i cannot
forget it and i cannot give up never
having it either
victoria spent the next few years making
her way from tajikistan
to europe where her sister now lives
eventually victoria made it to the u.s
she had freed herself from the mortal
dangers of her childhood
but she still wasn't free you're in the
united states
we'll be free you can do pretty much
whatever you want
do you feel free i was yearning for that
feminine
feeling remember when i put the burqa on
it made me feel
free but i thought putting this western
skirt and this headband on it will make
me also
again feel the same powerful feelings
but i had a little bump on that road
because closer to a mirror i got there
was a fuzzy
mustache start growing that was
terrifying terrifying to think that it
actually will become like my father's
with full face
beard i was tired of acting as a man
it was exhausting 24 7. so first i
decided to do my
facial it took me almost a year and a
half to do
electrolysis and lasers and all that is
the most
it's extremely painful thing then
why don't i just do the entire surgery
all back to back
i went to colombia had 18 surgeries back
to back
we have a saying about freedom
it's not just walls and bars
sometimes it's just the mind
you're right being free from
anything and anyone is the best thing we
can ever experience as a human being
i hope you do all the things you
want to do you've earned them thank you
so much
thank you
victoria has traveled a long road to
freedom
she was born in a country at civil war
survived becoming an orphan
escaped becoming a suicide bomber
but the hardest ordeal was the last
having the courage to free the person
she truly is
[Music]
abraham lincoln said those who deny
freedom to others
deserve it not for themselves
but the war for universal freedom is far
from won
and the battle lines only move forward
slowly
around the world millions of people
still live in slavery
women still struggle
to be granted the same rights as men
others
just want to be allowed to be the person
they know they are
inside it's been truly humbling to meet
those people who fought so hard for
their freedoms
their stories are a shocking reminder of
how vigilant we must be to protect human
rights
but they also give me a glimmer of hope
that one day those rights
will apply to all of us
[Music]
you